le ministère des transports de l'ontario
va t'il à contre-courant de la sagesse
dictée par les chiffres sur les
accidents en hiver compilées par le
ministère québécois des transports ou un
seau contraire le gouvernement québécois
qui agit comme une maman trop
protectionniste due aux conditions des
chemins en hiver non ce n'est pas
démontré encore selon les statistiques
que j'ai pu consulter la part de nos
divers incidents dramatiques tous les
accusés et les dommages et et la
sécurité des personnes du ministère des
transports du québec invoque une
réduction de 18 % du nombre de victimes
d'accidents de la route avec des pneus
d'hiver
mais il faut toutefois être prudent
avant de tirer des conclusions à partir
de ces chiffres
selon l'avis même d'une porte parole du
ministère québécois des transports
solène le nez on le constate que oui
depuis l'obligation de l'univers il ya
une amélioration mais on ne peut pas
attribuer différents clairement
seulement on part en part de nicolas
puisque leurs données sur les accidents
et le parti vert est que dans 22% des
cas on n'avait pas de donner ce qu'ils
étaient chauffés par le véhicule intrus
dans le quart des cas on crée pas
l'ontario justifie sa décision de ne pas
rendre obligatoire les pneus d'hiver en
affirmant que selon une enquête
indépendante réalisée il ya quatre ans
il n'existe pas suffisamment de preuves
qu'une telle mesure a eu un impact
important sur le nombre d'accidents de
la route en 2005 pourtant une autre
enquête nationale cette fois avait
révélé que 38 % des accidents survenus
en hiver au pays impliqué au moins un
véhicule équipé seulement deux pneus
d'été ou quatre saisons
puis lorsque le mercure tombe sous les 7
degrés celsius les pneus d'hiver serait
scientifiquement supérieur même sur une
route sèche
c'est ce qu'avance pour leur part des
manufacturiers de pneus d'hiver au pays
déjà à partir de lettres degré non moins
de l'adhérence avec le 3 jean philippe
st-pierre et directeur adjoint à la
recherche et aux affaires publiques
assez à québec sont preuve des débats
qui va être
lisez donc il va en fait un peu écrasée
sur la surface et qui va à berry
davantage dans ceux des technologies qui
s'améliore dernières années les
constructeurs font des efforts
évidemment considérable pour avoir des
revenus qui sont plus performants et
donc il n'est pas pourri et donc on a
quelque part dieu qui dégage bien la
neige dégage bilingue et doux qui
concerne son adhérence donc son
élasticité qui vont adhérer davantage ou
plus ou beaucoup bitume
tant mieux oui son devance par contre on
a toujours utilisé la sensibilisation il
faut faire a fait appel à l'intelligence
des gens pour faire leurs changements de
tenues des quais températures autour de
darwin du 31 octobre quand même qui est
inquiet qui est une bonne marque si on
veut que l'expression mailing des
registres
c'est toujours comme ça chaque année
c'est pas tout le monde qui prévoit 100
puis je pense que tout le monde on est
pareils on attaque il ya et la neige
pour prendre rendez vous pour changer
les pneus au dans mon corps en fait
toutes les preuves ont été faites
on est dans un pays en fille qu il était
vivant devraient en fait j'ai même déjà
dit qu'on laquelle des femmes c'est trop
tard le chroniqueur automobile québécois
benoit charette
j'ai fait le décompte je bats neige
depuis début d'octobre au québec qui a
eu déjà deux bordées hills a recouvert
la seule les routes
il y avait du verglas aujourd'hui donc
la caisse de charme à mon avis et c'est
une sécurité supplémentaire parce que
c'est drôle
quelques compagnies d'assurances du
comté l'ontario offrent des créneaux aux
assureurs qui en détenait du val examen
8 jugent que ce n'est pas nécessaire a
obligé la province de l'ontario a choisi
d'adopter en 2015 un règlement modifiant
la loi sur les assurances afin de forcer
les compagnies d'assurance à offrir un
meilleur prix aux détenteurs de pneus
d'hiver
ce rabais peut être de l'ordre de 3 à 5%
selon bureau d'assurance du canada
dans les faits ce rabais se limite
souvent au montant symbolique de 10 $
par année
un reportage de radio canada
international